والآن قد يكون المقاتلون الحوثيون المدعومين من إيران
في اليمن قد انضموا إلى الصراع
مع تقرير البنتاغون عن أن
مدمرة تابعة للبحرية الأمريكية في البحر الأحمر أسقطت
صواريخ كروز ربما كانت متجهة نحو
إسرائيل. مزيد من التفاصيل الآن من آرين
ليبرمان تقرير من
البنتاغون عن مدمرة تابعة للبحرية الأمريكية تعمل
في البحر الأحمر، اعترضت ثلاثة
صواريخ كروز وعددًا من الطائرات بدون طيار
يقول البنتاغون إنها ربما كانت متجهة
نحو إسرائيل، مما يشير إلى
احتمال فتح جبهة جديدة أو على
الأقل جهة فاعلة جديدة فيما تخشى الولايات المتحدة
أن يصبح صراعًا إقليميًا متنامًا.
الصراع وفقا للبنتاغون يوم
الخميس قوات الحوثيين في اليمن ومن
الجدير بالذكر أن قوات الحوثيين
المدعومة من إيران تطلق طائرات بدون طيار
وصواريخ كروز شمالا على طول البحر الأحمر
باتجاه إسرائيل واعترضت المدمرة الأمريكية كارني مدمرة تابعة للبحرية الأمريكية
في البحر الأحمر
تلك الطائرات بدون طيار  كما وعد البنتاغون بأنه
سيواصل الدفاع ليس فقط عن الولايات المتحدة
ولكن أيضًا عن مصالحها وشركائها،
وهذه ليست المنطقة الوحيدة أو
المنطقة الوحيدة في الشرق الأوسط التي
نرى فيها وكلاء إيرانيين يحتمل أن
يستهدفوا قواتنا هناك.  كان هناك عدد
من هجمات الطائرات بدون طيار في العراق على مدار الـ
48 أو 72 ساعة الماضية التي استهدفتنا
وقوات التحالف، وعلى الرغم من أن
البنتاغون لم ينسب المصدر أو
يذكر الجهة المسؤولة، إلا أنها
تشبه الهجمات التي شنتها علينا وعلى
قوات التحالف في العراق.  تم إخراجها من قبل
وكلاء إيرانيين هناك، حيث تحاول
إدارة بايدن ووزير الدفاع
لويد أوستن منع
الصراع في غزة من الانتشار خارج
حدود القطاع الساحلي
وإلى بقية الشرق الأوسط، وقد
شهدنا بالفعل احتجاجات في عدد
سفارات الولايات المتحدة في المنطقة والآن
اعتراض تلك الطائرات بدون طيار وصواريخ كروز
في البحر الأحمر والهجمات
علينا وتحدث وزير دفاع قوات التحالف
لويد أوستن مع
نظيره الإسرائيلي وكذلك مع
عدد من القادة العرب لتوضيح هذه النقطة
أولاً أن الولايات المتحدة ستحمي
ظهر إسرائيل، وثانياً أن الولايات المتحدة قد
ركزت على أهمية
حماية المدنيين، وهذه محاولة
لمحاولة تخفيف بعض
التوتر، وربما بعض الغضب في المنطقة،
ولكن حتى في الوقت الذي حاولت فيه الولايات المتحدة ذلك.  منع
هذا الصراع من الانتشار إلى
المنطقة والذي يبدو إلى حد كبير وكأنه
احتمال حقيقي الآن أورين ليبرمان سي إن إن في
البنتاغون صحفي سي إن إن إبراهيم دمان قدم
تقريرًا حصريًا للخارج، لقد كنت
تشاهد مراسلاته ورأيت
إجلاءه من الشمال جنبًا إلى جنب مع نظيره.
زوجته رشا وابناهما البالغان من
العمر 11 و7 أعوام، هم الآن في
مكان وقع فيه إضراب كبير اليوم وأه
يقول إنهم يشربون المياه المخصصة
للمراحيض الآن ولكن هذا ما وصل إليه الأمر، وهذه
آخر رسالة له من
[  الموسيقى]
اليوم
ل